Freunde ich habe Hunger will ein paar
neue Spots testen und habe nur noch 10 €
im Portemonnaie wie gut trifft es sich
dass wir heute fünf verschiedene
fußspots für 10 € treffen natürlich
testen wir Sie natürlich habe ich fünf
mal 10 € deshalb schnacken wir nicht
lange rum und holen uns was zum
Frühstück
ein bisschen Pariser Lebensgefühl im
verregneten sommerlichen Köln wir sind
von Angelie und hier drin gibt es guten
Kaffee und unglaubliche Backwaren aber
auch wirklich richtig feine Sachen gehen
wir mal rein und schauen was hier noch
haben weil die sind eigentlich immer
fast ausverkauft
[Musik]
da fühlt man sich doch direkt besser man
hat einen wunderschönen Kaffee eine
Quiche Lorenz eine tatlett eine
Apfeltarte mit Blätterteig und ich sage
euch so viel all das hier ist qualitativ
allererste Klasse der Kaffee sieht auch
richtig gut aus ich wusste bis heute gar
nicht dass sie so guten Kaffee haben
aber ich meine wenn ihr so aussieht und
so schön gegossen ist dann muss er ja
gut sein wir haben für 9,90 € insgesamt
also fast 10 €, eine üppiges Frühstück
lass uns satt macht bei dem wir
gemütlich sitzen können mit Blick auf
die Dürener Straße und auch
akustischstraße aber hey alles in einem
absolut nice ich sage ich fange süß an
echt bist du krank ja ich bin schon
krank probieren wir das ganze schön warm
gemacht
der Boden also einen schönen Biss
bisschen knackig dann natürlich die
Masse von der Quiche schön saftig innen
drin diese schinkenstücke
herzhaftes leckeres Frühstück direkt die
süße Tat dazu fein geschnittener Apfel
wie gesagt wenn ihr könnt holt euch paar
Schokolade wenn ihr zu spät seid nehmt
was von den anderen alles ist gut
die sieht unspektakulär aus ne die
schmeckt richtig gut du siehst richtig
schön die einzelnen Schichten vom
Blätterteig der zerfällt in deinem Mund
Apfel ist schön karamellisiert durch
Packung unglaublich lecker ein
unglaubliches Frühstück für unter 10 €
nicht umsonst ist die Bäckerei auch
ausgezeichnet als eine der besten
Deutschlands dieser tiktok Channel hat
mich übrigens inspiriert das Video jetzt
zu drehen Horus food Cologne der Macht
unter 10 € über 10 € mal vorbei
Ehrenmann habe ich gerade gesehen folgt
mir sogar auf tiktok Kuss getauscht ich
folge jetzt auch zurück also schaut
einmal vorbei falls ihr noch ein paar
weitere Zeug Einfall von dem testen wir
heute auch weiter geht's mit dem
nächsten Sport
wir sind hier in der Salzgasse am
Heumarkt ihr seht schon Kölner Altstadt
seht ihr mich relativ selten aber eine
Sache für mich hierher der Account den
ihr gerade gesehen habt hat die
briefkurve gut eigentlich eine Kölner
Institution gezeigt bei der ich aber
noch nie war kriegt man ganzjährige
Kuchen nicht nur auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
und wir gucken uns mal an in welchen
außergewöhnlichen Zusammenstellung ist
dort rein gibt wir gucken jetzt mal wie
diese schmecken und wie teuer sie sind
[Musik]
Dankeschön danke herrlich guck dir das
mal an oldenbraun frittiert dazu
Apfelmus was willst du mehr ich glaube
ganz viele Leute haben das noch nie
gegessen in Deutschland in Deutschland
aber es ist schon so ein Weihnachtsmarkt
Klassiker schon aber ich glaube auch
schon zum rheinisches Ding sollen wir
uns dann reinsetzen also könnte man wenn
ihr keine Baustelle wäre das war mein
Gedanke aber ich nehme jetzt mal hier so
ein Reibekuchen gebt den einmal ins
Apfelmus das ist so einfach und so gut
hoffe ich zumindest
der Crunch Test ist auf jeden Fall
bestanden die sind fertig die sind
knusprig die sind salzig
5,60 € dafür in so einer touristischen
Lage in der Qualität einfach ein Traum
Grüße gehen raus gut Guide ganz geil die
einfachen Sachen sind ja die leckersten
manchmal ne wirklich jeden Kuchen auf
dem Weihnachtsmarkt gibt die hier sind
eine ganze Ecke besser und ganzjährig
verfügbar rebekuchen gut schaut mal
vorbei die Damen vor Ort sind auch sehr
nett das finde ich geil wir sind sehr
freundlich ab geht's zum nächsten Sport
[Musik]
nächster Spot cumru Baba der kumru ist
Baba was heißt
das Essen wahrscheinlich
was das ist ich habe es auch noch nie
gegessen ich weiß nur hier kriegen wir
es für einen fairen Preis in einem
schönen selbstgebackenen Brot und so wie
ich das verstehe es kommt nur eine
Variation von verschiedenen türkischen
aufschnitten die in ein frisch
angetrostetes Brot gegeben werden mit
einer schönen Käsesoße darüber klingt
nach Cheat klingt nach lecker gucken wir
mal rein was wir bekommen
[Musik]
der Originale kumuru aus ist mir hier in
Köln zubereitet das sieht wirklich aus
als bräuchte man dafür ein Waffenschein
wir haben darauf drei Sorten Fleisch
Rindswurst Fleischwurst Sucuk oben drauf
einmal dieser schöne Schmelzkäse und die
zwei haussoßen einmal eine scharfe
Cocktailsauce und die wiederkommen Soße
wegen der alle wiederkommen deshalb
heißt sie auch so ich bin gespannt ob
ich auch wieder kommen werde ich glaube
die Chancen stehen gut
in meinem Kopf hatte ich irgendwie sowas
dönerartiges erwartet geschmacklich ist
das was ganz anderes wir haben dieses
weiche Brot diesen türkischen Aufschnitt
man kann sich da reinlegen mit Getränk
bekommt man das Ganze für 9 Euro auch
hier sind wir somit unter zehn sogar mit
Getränk etwas weil ich so noch nie
gegessen habe und eine dicke Empfehlung
von mir
mit dem Waffenschein stimmt schon das
kann ich nämlich auch ausmachen
auf dem Brot da kommt einfach direkt das
Fleisch drauf ja das keine Butter oder
fertig
den ganzen Saft der geht in das Brot
rein man sieht es auch so ein bisschen
krank Leute das war wirklich lecker was
ganz anderes aber ein Sport habe ich
schon da sehen wir uns jetzt es gibt
eigentlich wollte ich gerade den Namen
des Ladens sagen aber ich habe gerade
mit dem Besitzern gesprochen und die
meinen bitte nicht fehlen bitte keine
Werbung wir hatten letztens jemand der
Werbung gemacht hat und wir können
unsere Stammkunden sonst nicht mehr
bedienen wenn wir noch mehr Leute
bekommen finde ich sehr korrekt deshalb
zeige ich euch jetzt den nächsten Tipp
[Musik]
ihr seht das ist ein Tag später ich habe
was anderes an weil unser nächster Sport
hatte leider gestern zu Samstag Ruhetag
Kaffee 1980 einer meiner Favorit secret
Spots hier in Köln wir sind heute für
eine ganz besondere Sache da das Band
nie
[Musik]
ehrlich guckt euch an was hier habe
gerade noch die Inhaberin getroffen wir
haben ja schon mal gedreht für das
geheimtipps-video wenn wir die verborgen
gezeigt die ist aber mit 13,90 €
eindeutig zu teuer für das Video hier
habe ich jetzt einen Band nie das ist
eine weitere Spezialität von dem Laden
wirklich unglaublich gut 7,50 vegane
Version mit Tofu es gibt noch welche für
850 glaube ich mit Pult beef und Schwein
aber das hier ist wirklich einfach drauf
aber schauen wir uns einfach noch mal
gemeinsam an wir haben hier so fein
geschnittene Gurken geräucherten Tofu
angebraten unten drin eingelegtes Gemüse
Karotten bisschen Chili und Koriander
muss man natürlich nicht bestellen kann
man dazu bestellen ich weiß viele
mögen's nicht all das in einem schönen
knusprigen Brot
normalerweise kann man natürlich auch
sehr sehr gut dort sitzen aber alles ist
voll wie ihr seht und deswegen nehmen
das ist wirklich einfach so lecker ich
liebe den Laden wir sind leider viel zu
selten da hier vorne war eben als unser
altes Büro das ist mittlerweile Erics
Studio also könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen
in die Beschreibung daylight Studio
Cologne kann man mieten für Shootings
und so aber das hier ist geil das hier
ist lecker das macht mich glücklich und
für unter 10 €, das wahrscheinlich mit
einer der besten Sachen die man sich
hier in Köln holen kann
der perfekte Mittag dieser frische
Geschmack bringt sich nicht so aus dem
Konzept ja
Leute ich habe es gemerkt 10 Euro können
einen richtig weit bringen hier in der
Domstadt Köln hat euch das Video Spaß
gemacht schreibt es mal in die
Kommentare wollt ihr das aus anderen
Städten wollt ihr wissen was man zum
Beispiel in Berlin in Düsseldorf in
Hamburg mit wenig Geld bekommt dann
mache ich das auch aber wenn ihr Lust
habt bis zum nächsten Mal ciao
[Musik]